in recent years there's really been an
emphasis on rescuing a dog rather than
buying one from a
backyard or unlicensed breeder but what
if you really have your heart set on a
certain breed of dog maybe you really
want a poodle or you want a pug
can you find a purebred in a rescue
group well with a little bit of research
and some patience the answer is yes
this playful pup ended up in rescue just
a few days after she was born
owners surrender dogs of all ages for
all different reasons
they no longer live in a house going
into a hospital or
elderly person who might be going to the
nursing home and really can't take the
dog
laura van epp used to show and breed
dobermans
now she helps find them homes through
las vegas doberman and dachshund rescue
most of them are very attractive unless
you were an expert dog show person than
going to westminster you wouldn't
know the difference between them and any
other dog that's the case with most
breed specific rescues beautiful dogs
who just need another chance
local shelters seem to have the same
types of dogs
over and over chances are that golden or
yorkie you're looking for
has already been claimed by their breed
rescue group
you may never even see them though if
somebody comes in with a cocker and it's
a full cocker i usually get the call we
have a dog here on a surrender can i
give him your number absolutely
and that's that's how it's been going on
cocker's spaniel recovery foundation
like most rescues have more time to
evaluate a dog
and more time to vet an adopter
you'll need to apply pay an adoption fee
and be willing to have a home check
i personally do a lot of the home visits
myself i sit down and talk to the client
i ask them some questions we try to
figure out what their lifestyle is who
lives in their house
what kind of temperament and size and
energy level would look
be good with these groups you'll have
someone experience
with that breed helping you succeed at
becoming
a forever family it gives you the
benefit of the
new forever home people they get a nice
dog that just needs a little tune up
by the way this is the list there are
dozens upon dozens of rescue groups in
southern nevada
and you can find any type of breed that
you might be looking for now a lot of
times they do not have puppies
but take it from me i adopted two golden
retrievers from the southern nevada
golden retriever rescue group
both of them less than a year old you
just gotta apply you gotta wait
and sometimes you just get lucky